The situation with Donald Trump's legal team
is becoming more of a soap opera than anything
I recall seeing over the last 25 years relating
so directly to the president of the United
States, Donald Trump's former lawyer.
And almost special counsel Sidney Powell is
now claiming she's been banned from the White
House.
I don't know whether to start with the new
part or let's start with the new part and
then we'll go backwards and I'll catch you
up on everything.
So listen to this.
Sidney Powell telling Fox News she's been
banned from the White House and from speaking
to Trump.
Check this out.
This is during an interview on Fox News where
anchor John Roberts is interviewing Republican
strategist Karl Rove is General Flynn's attorney,
Sidney Powell, who suggests that after a meeting
on Friday night, she's been banned from the
White House in a statement to Fox News saying,
I've been blocked by White House counsel and
others from seeing or speaking to the president
since I raised the public formal findings
that even more evidence of foreign interference
from Iran and China.
I'm told that she still has the ability to
call the president.
She's not on any kind of do not admit list
at the White House.
But I do know that there are many people in
senior positions at the White House who would
prefer that Miss Powell and others stay away
from.
OK, so now that we've seen that, you really
have to understand the back story to comprehend
the level of absurdity that that is going
on here.
So shortly after the election, Donald Trump
tweeted about Sydney Powell as one of the
lawyers representing him.
He tweeted on November 14th, Rudy Giuliani,
Joseph DiGenova, Victoria Toensing, Sydney
Powell and Jenna Ellis, a truly great team,
added to our lawyers and representatives very
clear.
Trump says Sydney Powell is part of my team.
Great.
Shortly after that, Sydney Powell joined Donald
Trump's lawyer, Rudy Giuliani and John Ellis
and others at this bizarre basement press
conference where they made all sorts of very
unusual claims, none of them based, in fact.
And this is the major press conference at
which Sydney Powell started making the radical
claims about Hugo Chavez and Tifa and George
Soros were part of a plan to steal the election
for Trump.
And this was so crazy.
Then it got the Trump campaign to put out
a statement basically distancing from and
and sort of like firing Sydney Powell, saying
Sydney Powell is practicing law on her own.
She is not a member of the Trump legal team.
She is also not a lawyer for the president
in his personal capacity.
So it seemed Sidney Powell was out if she
was ever in, which Trump said she was she
was then out of the Trump campaign until last
Friday.
She shows up at the Oval Office and she's
the one talking to Trump about maybe martial
law.
Maybe we see voting machines and all sorts
of other wacky ideas, as well as reportedly
telling others in the room who were saying,
you know, sir, that's illegal, saying you
guys are quitters.
That made instant headlines because No.
One, it's nuts.
And No.
Two, supposedly Trump was distanced from Sydney
Powell.
So how is she in the Oval Office and how is
she potentially going to be made special counsel?
And then now this, which is Sydney Powell
says she's been banned from the White House
and from speaking to Trump, and now they're
all going after her.
Here's another clip of Karl Rove during his
same interview with Fox News just bashing
Sydney Powell.
This Powell has peddled theories that have
little basis.
In fact, the idea that Hugo Chavez from the
grave was somehow involved in stealing this
year's election and that I mean, she was poured
out in a courtroom recently where all of her
expert witnesses, which one of them was so
highly prized that he had to have a code name
and couldn't be revealed.
And he was a she sold him as a highly expert
military intelligence analyst, turned out
to be a midlevel computer programmer from
Dallas who couldn't even pass the entrance
exams for the three hundred and Fifth Intelligence
Brigade Intelligence School.
He couldn't even pass the exams and he was
her high level advocate.
She had another expert who couldn't tell the
difference between election precincts and
townships in Minnesota and Michigan and claimed
that one hundred and fifty one percent turnout
in Wayne County, Michigan, when any idiot
with access to Google and the and the county
election returns could have seen that the
turnout was fifty one percent, not one hundred
and fifty one.
I mean, what she has done to sort of, you
know, throw mud on the president through her
Addicks is unbelievable that the president
has been so ill served by this crowd and she's
chief among them.
What I absolutely love about this is that
Karl Rove is absolutely right in his criticism
of Sidney Powell.
But the things that Rudy Giuliani and Jenna
Ellis have been peddling are only marginally
less crazy than what Sidney Powell has been
saying.
Karl Rove and John Roberts now are framing
this as Woa, Sidney Powells nuts.
But actually, they're all nuts and their work
is totally worthless and going nowhere, but.
It's funny and it's sad and it's a bizarre
soap opera that seems never to end, but it
actually will end relatively soon and it'll
be much better for the country.
Now, there's lots of I've been seeing so many
different legal commentators and lawyers saying
the behavior of Rudy Giuliani, Sydney Powell
and Janet Ellis before a variety of courts
over the last month, month and a half really
does warrant complaints to bar associations
and that these are the types of actions that
should should really get somebody disbarred.
I don't think it's likely that that will happen.
But understand that these figures have crossed
over from being like, I guess, what we would
call legal lawyers into being almost like
cult activist type figures, where even if
they were to be disbarred for the things that
they've been doing at this point, they can
launch off into being TV lawyers for all sorts
of right wing groups or radical organizations
or reactionary movements.
So it's almost irrelevant at this point, although
I don't think it's a bar, it goes beyond the
facts to say how how could these people even
really still hold a bar association licenses?
But that's probably more of a story for post
inauguration.